[Music]
hello dear friends Welcome to our
question and answer program I'd like to
know we appreciate you turn tuning in
every week
uh for half an hour to uh listen to the
questions and the answers that we
provide as a result of our research uh
we want to encourage you to continue
sending your questions uh the address
you will find on the screen TVM tv.org
once again TVM
tv.org we might not be able to answer
them immediately when we receive them
because we put them in line according to
the order in which we receive them
however we will eventually get uh to the
point of answering your questions so
keep them coming I have with me uh a
dear friend and uh fellow worker here at
Secrets unsealed in Su TV Pastor David
Salazar it's always a pleasure to work
with you yes Pastor it's a blessing and
a privilege for me as well to work with
you and to answer the questions that our
friends are sending us amen I also want
to remind you that um the programs that
we produce uh require financial
assistance so we appreciate greatly the
donations that you send us so that we
can continue doing these programs uh we
also appreciate your prayers especially
because uh through prayer we are able to
continue working for the Lord sharing
his message with the church and with the
world uh God bless you all and um now
we're going to have a word of prayer to
begin like to ask Pastor Salasar to pray
and then we'll get right into our
questions let us pray
Heavenly Father we come before you
tonight today to be able to come and ask
from you the most precious gift which is
the gift of the Holy Spirit we know that
we don't deserve it we don't uh we don't
have any claim to it but you so
graciously have provided for us and are
willing to give us if we ask and Lord we
need the Holy Spirit to understand your
word and to be able to express the
thoughts and the answers that you want
the world to know so I pray that you
will help us to have Clarity of Mind of
speech and that whatever we say may be
according to your will and according to
your word I pray of these in Jesus name
amen
amen well uh what is the first question
that we have on the docket well pastor
we have the first question that a friend
sent from San Francisco Romy and it says
the question
says Dear Pastor bore is the Sabbath
celebrated in the unfallen worlds too do
they have a 7-Day weekly cycle too will
the Sabbath be celebrated in heaven
during the Millennium is there a weekly
cycle in
heaven if God created the universe
during the creation is it true that the
unfallen worlds were also created at the
same time or first six days of creation
thank you and God bless you and your
ministry ROM me from San Francisco a lot
of questions that Romy has so we'll try
to go with one at a time right yeah the
first one is I guess will the Sabbath be
celebrated in the unfallen worlds what
can we say about that you know first of
all the unfallen worlds uh existed
before the creation of this world uh and
we know that because uh uh Satan uh went
to those worlds to try and convince them
to uh you know disobey God and he was
not successful so we know that there
were worlds also job 38:7 says that when
this world was created uh the sons of
God shouted for joy and the stars of
Heaven sang uh stars of Heaven represent
the angels and the sons of God were the
representatives of the worlds so we know
that they existed at creation they had
been created before now as far as the
Sabbath being celebrated on Fallen
worlds uh I haven't been able to find
find any information uh that answers
that specific question I have my own
idea about it and you know when I'm
sharing my opinion I'll let everybody
know it's my opinion right when we don't
have light on the specific question um I
believe that God has synchronized the
universe so that created beings have the
Sabbath as the sign uh of the
Creator uh so in other words uh Heaven
the heavenly the worlds uh are
synchronized to uh the time schedule
here uh but we don't know for sure if
God created those worlds in seven days
whether the Sabbath uh is kept in in all
of those worlds uh you know or whether
God gave them a different sign so um you
know I wish we had a clear answer but we
don't have any Revelation on this
particular Point correct correct and now
the question also that it said is is
will will we celebrate the Sabbath in
heaven I mean during the Millennium
because obviously Isaiah 66 speaks of in
the life after the um you know after the
Millennium the new Earth the new heavens
and we'll have the Sabbath there but I
suppose the question that these
individual has is in regards to the
Millennium specifically the Millennium
the a thousand years that will be in
heaven will there be also the Sabbath be
kept there during that time what is the
uh well we don't have any clear answer
on that particular Point either um you
know we would assume that uh that
perhaps we'll be keeping the Sabbath but
the problem is the Sabbath is determined
by the
sun you know by the rising and setting
of the sun um you know is God does God
have a son up there that establishes a
seven-day cycle we don't know uh on this
Earth during the Millennium there will
be no Sabbath observance uh because when
Jesus returns the sun moon and stars
will be moved out of their places
correct uh which means that this Earth
will be in uh Darkness for a thousand
years yes so if there's no rising and
Setting Sun uh there would be no way to
calculate the um the 7-Day cycle uh so
but in heaven um we'll know if we get
there and I I trust that everybody's
making plans to get there yeah the
Millennium right okay pastor and uh me
see well I I suppose we have answered
these questions I know that like you
mentioned there's not a lot of evidence
in spir Prophecy or the Bible to these
specific questions but I think that the
overall idea is after the Millennium
while we when we come back to the new
Earth and is created there will be then
the Sabbath again there will be a
restoration to that s day cycle
experience for sure yeah and Isaiah 66
makes that very clear correct that um
after the millennium after the
destruction of the wicked uh God is
going to make a new heavens and a new
Earth and he's going to reestablish the
s-day cycle because we're going to come
to worship before the Lord from month to
month and from Sabbath to Sabbath and
the month is determined by the moon and
the the day and the Sabbath is
determined by the sun amen okay well
hopefully this gives some insight to
answers to our friend Romy but uh again
we thank you for the questions now the
next question Pastor is one that it's uh
I think the first time we had this
question here in the program is in
regards to um this comes from Joi and it
says the following some people have
criticized the SDA the 7day Adventist
logo claim it it claiming it has satanic
elements can you provide more details on
this this is a a question on the symbol
or the logo of the 7 Day Adventist
Church so Pastor let's talk about these
a little bit more you know I I really
resent the idea that the logo is satanic
yeah
um probably let me see if uh the people
who are watching are able to see the
logo probably most 7th Day advence have
seen the logo uh this is what it looks
like and uh basically it has uh a Bible
an Open Bible in the middle it has a
cross and then it has flames of fire uh
surrounding an imaginary Globe the globe
isn't there but it's understood that
there is a globe and the fire represents
the fact that it's going around the
world MH um now this logo the reason why
it was adopted is because before 1980
when this one was adopted um each
denominational entity had its own logo
mhm most of them had three Angels on the
logo but there was a great variety of
logos uh each conference each uh each
entity had their own logo so what they
decided to do was to standardize the
logo and make one logo that would
represent the entire Seventh Adventist
Church which is used
everywhere uh so there's not some
Sinister uh plot you know to change the
logo now some people complain that uh
the Three Angels aren't here
and you know overtly they're not right
uh but the three Flames that are you
know going around the globe right
there's actually actually not six
although it looks like there's six lines
actually it's the fire going around the
globe um represents the Holy Spirit of
course the open book represents the
Bible and the cross represents salvation
through Christ MH uh so I don't see
anything Sinister in the logo I don't
know whether you have any reservations
about it no I remember actually when I
was uh young going or or hearing rather
some debates in certain parts of the
church that were not very happy or
content with the new logo specifically
because the Three Angels were not there
presently they were not really seen
overly seen um so I remember hearing a
little bit of these arguments back and
forth and like you mentioned some
individuals were basically taking you
know certain things in in the sense that
they were not you know really portraying
to what we know as a truth that not
Three Angels were very becoming more
ecumenical uh kind of going with the
mainstream Christianity idea of of a
flame and so forth but um in spite of
the fact that I wish the logo personally
would have you know being signed with a
more clear definition of Three Angels
going around the world um
I don't see uh that that being or I
don't see the logo necessarily being
evil or Sinister in any way you know I
believe that it's a logo that was made
for the corpor you know for a corporate
identity of the church so that
everywhere we you know is more
identifiable but uh did they make the
best choice well you know that's the
decision for the leadership then you
know I don't know maybe I like I said I
would have probably Li The Three Angels
I think that a lot of people do miss
that and and I think that they maybe
that was a a perhaps a mistake in the
part of not keeping that identity very
specific to the atist church alive but
other than that I really think that
thinking that is negative or that is
something sinister or satanic about it I
think is really just making a uh you
know trying to make an issue out where
it's not an issue you know people uh
some people in the Adventist Church um
make a big issue out of small things yes
and it almost becomes their gospel right
another couple of examples is that Ellen
White has an obelisk on her the place
where she's buried and several family
members and they say oh the you know the
Obelisk that is a satanic symbol and
it's a Freemason symbol and so Ellen
White was a Freemason but if you do a
little research you find that Ellen
White condemns membership in secret
societies and she mentions the
Freemasons by name correct as don't join
and uh and then others you know they
criticize the Pathfinders oh the
Pathfinders you know that uh that is
satanic you know and and they go on and
on uh I was a Pathfinder director for
over 10 years in two
conferences and uh it's a wonderful
program you know it it teaches kids to
memorize the Bible it teaches them
discipline teaches them to to survive
you know camping out it teaches them to
march uh teach teaches them discipline
uh so so you know it's a it's a great
program to keep kids in the church but
some people say oh no that's that's
satanic so let's not get all caught up
in
mintia uh and conspiracy theories and
let's just get down to the seriously
important stuff amen amen well I hope
this answers your question dear Joi and
again uh continue to study God's word
and let's you know focus on the Lord so
let's continue with the next question
that comes from a Mia from London uh so
I I'm assuming this is England there is
a London somewhere here in the states a
couple of little cities but I believe
this is from England now we have this is
a lot of questions so we'll try to see
we can hit one by one and we'll just go
one answer and as time let us we'll
continue to the next one it says there
thank you so much for your ministry I
love all your shows and especially the
question and answer I like to know my
name is Mia and I'm writing to you from
BC London so it must be English
I have few questions for the pastor Bor
and the team pastors first question in
Deuteronomy 22 13 through 19 not sure
how can be Pro The Virginity of a girl
as not always in blood to be left after
on the sheets when she started her
sexual life just a small number of women
are living blood behind in this
situation can an inoc innocent life be
sacrificed
so this is the first question in regards
to proving whether or not a virgin was a
virgin in the in the first encounter
with her husband and so the question is
could that be an exception somebody not
bleed and not having the you know the
the the you know the blood the sheets
would that make the open the case for
somebody to be wrongfully accused what
could we say about that question you
know some of these ritual laws really
this isn't a ritual law it's a societal
law um you know some of them uh I think
that we're going to find uh an answer to
the rationale when we get to the kingdom
uh because uh uh you know I think that
the important thing here is uh virginity
and uh the the person uh you know who
asked this question brings up a
hypothetical situation right um but uh I
think that the the reason why this is
here mhm is to protect the importance of
the virginity yeah uh of of a girl uh
who's going to get married correct and
and it's interesting that in the text
that she you know from Deuteronomy as
you mentioned it's it's something that
God is trying to
protect the the woman and trying to make
sure that if a man has a real reason
to reject her as a wife there had to be
a a real reason that she that he found
out that she was not uh a virgin so uh
but I am assuming that God did implement
or when they were making judgment there
was going to be some sort of
Investigation it wasn't just like the
word of a man against the wife you know
there had to be more than just that this
would be one of the reasons and if he
could prove that experience happened
then he had a reason to reject her as a
wife so but it was not just so that you
know a woman a man would reject his wife
for whatever reason pity you know
decisions it had to be a reason of of of
real elements of she being willfully
lying to him and hiding something after
the fact uh but most of the time you
know before the marriage would happen
usually there was the families got
together they knew each other there was
a there was a process that would involve
the protection so that you know it would
be known even before a year they were
were going to be married they were to
know one another and they were already
you know dedicated to the marriage uh
this is what happened for example with
Joseph and Mary uh in you know parents
of Jesus or the well Mary the mother of
Jesus and Joseph The Stepfather of
Christ but he was deposed to be with her
long before the were the marriage was
happened and during that time they were
to arrange the marriage and they were
already enter into an agreement if
during that time you know she you know
the case of the scenario where a woman
would have not been faithful to her
promised husband
uh if that was the case and and he found
out even when they were married and
together that she was was not a virgin
then he had reasons and enough evidence
to you know to reject her but it was a
way to really
secure truly the the sanity of marriage
and help women and men to not just do
pity accusations without any proof so
this is really what it's you know the
main emphasis of these elements of the
story or the law yeah I think that
you're right on target when when you say
that is that uh you
know these laws were laws that were
established by a closed Society right
which was Israel MH you know they're
they're uh moral laws yes but they are
also societal
laws in some ways they reflect the the
mores of the surrounding
Nations and uh and so you know we might
not understand all the ins and outs
right of this but uh whatever God has
put in his word mhm it's because it's
the best right amen so the next question
is one that is also found in the same
chapter of Deuteronomy and this time is
verses 23 and 24 and the question is in
regards or or it says this way uh I
understand that is the Deuteronomy 2223
and 24 I understand that he's trying to
prevent fornication but as I can imagine
a girl that is raped is overpowered most
of the time threatened that if she will
scream will'll be killed I can only
imagine the hor horror of a raped victim
if she has an scream being petrified she
was meant to die I know I'm not to judge
the word of God in any way but I am
struggling to understand this passage
regarding the victim so I think that
it's probably you know Wise to read
those two
verses Deuteronomy 2223 and 24
and it says if a damel that is a virgin
be bethroned Beed unto a husband and a
man find her in the city and lie with
her then ye shall bring them both out
unto the Gate of the city and ye shall
Stone them with stones that they die the
damel because she cried not being in the
city and the men because he had humbled
his neighbor's wife he had humbled his
neighbor's wife so Thou shalt put away
evil from among
you so um in these two verses it's
clearly stating that if they are in the
city and she doesn't scream or or and I
think that the implication is that if
she consents to this you absolutely if
she's consenting to her being with
another man and she's bethroned she's
promised to another man this is not even
before she's already married this is the
that year that I explained to you before
you know that if she's in relationship
with somebody and they are found out
they are to be stoned both and and
that's where the crying out comes right
because if she's if if this is happening
and she's crying out
undoubtedly other individuals will come
to try and help her yeah right it's kind
of like today if a woman was being raped
uh you know there would be people around
who would come and they would prevent
that from occurring absolutely and let's
say that she's petrified in a scenario
but they will be crying they'll be sing
she'll go immediately to her parents no
it would not be in consent so I think
this very important to point you know
make the point that they not she not
cried is meaning that she consents to
that and she's right you know into this
situation uh you know but I feel that if
a woman who was abused and was a victim
the Lord would prevent her to be killed
being a victim of the sitation you know
so she probably would go straight to the
authorities to the judge Etc and and
play the case yeah and they examine
those cases before before anything was
done with the person who was accused
right right correct you know like in the
case of aen that's correct you there was
a whole process of investigation that
took place before uh he was actually
killed with his family uh because they
had kept the secret you know they knew
what he had done and so uh you know I
think that that the idea is that silence
would seem to indicate consent m um
although probably not always but that
would be the rule is that you know if
the woman isn't Kicking and Screaming
because she's being violated you know
maybe it's consensual and probably they
would have had to take it to a judge for
the judge to determine if it was
consensual or not correct there was a
process as you mentioned Pastor a due
process it was not just you know two
people grabbing stones and stoling them
they had to go through a a a process of
judgment um so those things could be
argued or or in favor or against okay
let's continue maybe well I don't know
if we have time for uh well this is a a
quick question I think we can answer
this is the third question she has it
says is it appropriate to have intimate
relations on Sabbath what can we say
about that Pastor you know we have
answered that question
before um you know that's a question
where the conscience of the person is
involved MH um you know there's a
principle in the Bible right not doing
your own will mhm nor seeking your own
pleasure correct uh but it doesn't
mention specifically having sexual
relations on Sabbath MH uh you know some
people might think that you know God
created uh sexual relations and it was
they were created the sixth day and the
seventh day you know they they might
have had sexual relations but I think
the seventh day probably was a day to
meditate upon the greatness of God upon
the greatness of creation you know more
not not on you wouldn't say that the
that sex was selfish at that time
because they they were they hadn't
sinned right but their focus was more on
the greatness of God and his creation
but I don't I don't go into the bedroom
to dictate what people should do you
know they have a conscience and if their
conscience bothers them then they they
they need to pay attention to their
conscience and it's important to like
you mentioned Pastor that understand the
principles uh perhaps the time for us to
you know think selfishly is really not
the way to to approach this this
scenario is to think more of how it
pleases the Lord and what is Right
according to his will and I believe that
you will find enough in the Bible to
lead you personally as you mentioned
it's a personal you know con conscious
decision but I think God will speak to
you and let you know you know what is
right if you don't feel comfortable it's
better than not to do it you know y well
we thank you once again for your time
and for allowing us to come to your
homes we bless we pray that the Lord May
bless you and keep you and see you in
another program of I like to know
[Music]